that's like the fourth time this week
four times this week that's too much
mila kunis and ashton kutcher are
settling this whole bathing debate once
and for all
yeah oh my god the mom and dad of two
took to instagram wednesday night to
poke fun at the backlash surrounding
their comments about how often they
bathe their kids
listen i get in too much trouble that's
the couple in their bathroom while their
kids take a shower and ashton he shares
his shock and horror at his wife quote
melting the children with water
what's going on
[Music]
oh my god water it's water you're
putting water on the children
are you trying to melt them
are you trying to injure them with water
this is ridiculous what's going on
we're bathing here that's like the
fourth time this week four times this
week
too much
that's great their body oils are gonna
be destroyed
what are you trying to do
yeah so all this comes after the two
famously got flack in july for revealing
how often they bathe their children
during an episode of dak shepard's
armchair expert podcast
if you can see the dirt on them clean
them yeah otherwise there's no point
when i had children i also didn't wash
them every day like i wasn't the parent
that bathed my newborns
ever but ashton and mila aren't alone
dax and his wife kristen bell defended
their pals sharing during an appearance
on the view that their own kids
eight-year-old lincoln and six-year-old
delta have a similar bathing routine we
bathe our children every single night
prior to bed is like the routine
and then somehow they just started going
to sleep on their own without the
routine and by george we had to start
saying like hey when's the last time you
bathed them yeah we forget sometimes
five six days goes on i mean they don't
smell so
but kristen didn't exactly agree with
her hubby there
well that's right they do
i'm a big fan of waiting for the stink
once you catch a whiff that's
that's biology's way of letting you know
you need to clean it up and all that
sparked what i'm calling the big online
bathing debate let me tell you guys
cardi b weighed in posing a simple
question on twitter asking what's up
with people saying they don't shower
it's giving itchy she also shared this
snap from her bathroom showcasing all
her lotions and potions alongside the
caption would you shower at my place
i gotta see it to believe it dwayne the
rock johnson confirmed he's on team
shower too tweeting his entire hygiene
routine nope i'm the opposite of a not
washing themselves celeb shower colds
when i roll out of bed to get my day
roll in shower warm after my workout
before work shower hot after i get home
from work face wash body wash exfoliate
and i sing off key in the shower
it is the consistent thing jake
gyllenhaal also entered the chat
confessing to vanity fair that more and
more he finds bathing to be quote less
necessary at times but jake wants to be
clear about one thing he does believe in
brushing his teeth adding that quote
good manners and bad breath get you
nowhere as for jody turner smith she
didn't even need to be asked if she and
her husband joshua jackson are team bath
time the queen and slim star tweeted in
part quote in this house we bathe i just
don't understand
meanwhile chris evans settled this
debate before it was even a debate
telling the today show about his hygiene
habits back in july 2020. i shower off
good time i'm a very clean person
and ladies and gentlemen with that i'm
off to support team shower
[Music]